[Musique]
si comme on le dit le cinéma est une
grande famille alors notre invité en est
un pilier depuis plus de 50 ans il
accompagne les acteurs et les actrices
il les rassure les conseillent les
bichonn les pousse dans leur
retranchement aussi en tant que
producteur aujourd'hui mais en tant
qu'agent pendant 20 ans le vivier
incroyable que nous avons dans le cinéma
et le théâtre français c'est lui en
grande partie qu'il a constitué il a
l'œil pour dénicher les pépites dénicher
les talents Binoche arstrup Adjani Weber
ba ginsbourg à tal je ne suis pas sûr
que quiconque est échappé à son regard à
son réseau à la toile qu' a tissé il
fallait bien une deuxième autobiographie
pour raconter cette vie hors norme le
dictionnaire de ma vie c'est là qu'il
décrit ses épreuves qu'il dévoile ses
réflexions sur l'époque et qu'il nous
livre les détails sur toutes ces
rencontres fascinantes mais comment les
a-t-il choisi d'ailleurs quels étai ces
critères un physique une voix une
personnalité une promesse comment
décide-t-on de faire monter un artiste
posons-lui toutes ses questions
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue à vous Dominique besnear et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
au Sénat dans ce dô Tournon que ce soit
en tant qu'agent ou en tant que
producteur qu'est-ce qui détermine votre
choix est-ce qu'il y a je le disais une
voix une promesse peut-être une
intuition en tout cas c'est vrai lorsque
c'est deux choses différentes lorsque
j'étais agent mais j'étais très
longtemps casting pendant 10 ans c'est
là où j'ai repéré beaucoup de de jeunes
acteurs comme Juliette Binoche comme
Emmanuel seignet comme Béatrice D euh et
donc pourquoi je les ai choisis parce
que je les ai choisis je les ai repéré
ensuite il faut quand même dire que
c'est le metteur en scène qui les a
engagé parce que maintenant on a
tendance à à à me faire porter beaucoup
de belles choses mais en même temps je
travaillais pour des films et pour des
productions mais c'est vrai que j'étais
un agent un peu ce qu'on appelait le le
casting sauvage parce qu'on m'a souvent
appelé pour essayer de dénicher des
nouveaux visages et des nouveau talent
et il y a tous ceux dont on parle et il
y a tous ceux dont on parle pas qui
malheureusement n'ont pas fait cette
carrière je suis pas non plus un démurge
mais c'est vrai que que en fin de compte
j'ai j'éta j'ai toujours été observateur
et j'aime bien en fin de compte regarder
les gens je suis capable de de m'asseoir
sur une terrasse de café comme faisait
piala et Godar il regarder passer les
gens et et ça m'intéresse et du reste
toujours en tant que producteur vous
avez alors en en tant que producteur ben
oui mais par exemple là je suis en train
de signer mon livre dans des salons et
le problème c'est très long avec moi
parce que des gens me racontent leur vie
pourquoi ils me racontent leur vie parce
que je sais pas parce que je sais pas
euh vous inspirez confiance B j'espère
et ils pensent peut-être qu'ils ont une
part de l'agent que j'ai été de l'agent
de de de Béatrice zal ou Nathalie baay
voilà moi j'ai le droit à son écoute
peut-être c'est ça en fait de compte un
acteur ça doit avoir une harmonie moi
voilà quand j'étais un un je un agent il
fallait avoir une harmonie c'estàdire
pas forcément le plus beau visage mais
le visage qu'on retient je vous raconter
autre chose lorsque je faisais du
casting et que j'allais dans les agences
de mannequin il y avait les photos de
des plus belles des plus beaux
mannequins de de de même d'Europe du
monde et je les regardais elles étaient
belles je tournais la page je l'oubliais
en fin de compte celle qui me retenait
celle qui avait quelque chose de
différent peut-être une mouche peut-être
quelque chose de de différent une
expression différente est-ce que ce sont
des êtres à part les acteurs et les
actrices on dit beaucoup qu'ils sont
particulièrement sensibles voir
susceptible à fleur de peau est-ce qu'il
faut les rassurer est-ce que ce sont des
êtres à part bien sûr faut les rassurer
mais en même temps faut pas non plus moi
j'ai été proche de d'une politique qui
est en photo ici excusez-moi elle
demandait à être assuré autant même si
n'écoutait rien de ce qu'on lui disait
elle était fallait la r on y viendra
vous parlez de ces Golen Royal on en
parlera tout c'est vous savez dès dès
qu'on est dès qu'on est présentateur dès
qu'on est journaliste dès qu'on côtoile
public on a besoin d'avoir un un d'être
assuré ou d'avoir un conseil ou de
savoir comment ça s'est passé mais
est-ce qu'il vous est arrivé de forcer
le trait du coup d'exagérer un petit peu
de dire mais oui tu es la meilleure mais
oui tu es le meilleur tu es le plus beau
tu es la plus belle est-ce que moi j'ai
toujours j'ai toujours essayé d'être
sincère mais quelquefois et alors c'est
une époque aussi qui a bougé parce que
lorsque j'étais à agent et que je disais
à un acteur faut que tu travailles c'est
pas là encore maintenant ils sont
tellement presser les jeunes acteurs qui
vous quittent dans la minute il va chez
ils vont chez un autre agent à mon
époque on pouvait avoir des discussions
on pouvait se dire il y avait plus
d'humilité alors du côté des acteurs ils
acceptaient qu'on leur fasse des
reproches ou qu'on leur donne des
conseils il y avait plus le sens du
travail ouou et moins d'être rapide tout
va trop vite et que maintenant je parle
un peu comme un un vieux con mais par
moment dire le le temps le temps de
réfléchir le temps de parler le temps de
se dire mais maintenant voilà un jeune
acteur il a à peine sorti du cours qui
s'est fait des photos il a peine lu la
Piège jusqu'au bout il fait et puis il
veut un agent le nombre là à par exemple
j'étais à à comment au man il y a tous
les parents qui viennent me voir ou les
grands les grands-parents ça mimux ils
amènent leurs photos ils achètent le
livre d'abord pour me faire plaisir on
n'ose pas vous redire mais il y a votre
fils il y a mon fils qui veut être
acteur voyez sa photo alors est-ce que
vous pourriez lui trouver un agent je
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a fait bah il est
au cours bah qu'il aille travailler un
peu au cours et après il va se faire
remarquer et peut-être qu'il aura un
agent donc vous voyez tout ça c'est la
téléréalité c'est presque triste non tel
que vous le racontez il y a une
recherche de notoriété immédiate c'est
comme comme un but en soi comme comme un
but en soi mais beaucoup la les la
téléréalité est vraiment irresponsable
de faire on pense qu'on peut être une
vedette tout de suite mais même certains
acteurs actrices qui sont des bons
acteurs ou des des jeunes actrices qu'on
la couverture de Elle elles pensent
qu'elles sont qu'elles sont Natalie BA
ou Catherine deeuve mais il y a tout un
travail faut marquer faut marquer les
esprits faut marquer le l'émotion et
puis est-ce que ça doit être un but tout
simplement oui mais parce que voilà et
puis vous savez que certaines actrices
je actrices elle préfère avoir être il
n'est géré d'une marque que un rôle h
vous savez quand elles sont dans une
marque moi certaine que je vois angouè
ça m'amuse elle m'a dit donc je peux tu
me prends dans le jury et je peux venir
avec ma marque Mo j'ai dit je veux que
tu viennes avec un bon film oui il y a
un vrai mélange d'art et de business en
fait il y a quelque chose de cet ordre
quand vous racontez pour la série 10 %
qui a été un carton absolu diffusé sur
France Télévision inspiré de votre
expérience d'agent je crois que vous
avez eu les plus grandes difficultés à
convaincre au au départ en tout cas tant
que la série n'était pas installée et à
succès les comédiens d'avoir de
l'autodérision sur eux et d'avoir des
des des stars des comédiens et des
comédiennes qui acceptent de jouer leur
propre rôle tout en se moquant d'eux-mêm
eu comment vous l'expliquez est-ce qu'il
y avait une peur d'écorner son image
est-ce que c'est particulièrement
français non c'est par exemple en même
temps je peux le dire maintenant Sophie
Marceau elle a pas voulu le faire alors
que j'adore Sophie Marceau j'aiété son
agent pendant je sais pas 15 ans ou 20
ans mais elle avait peur au début parce
que que que les gens confondent la
fiction et ce qu'elle est réellement non
mais il y en a confusé puis en même
temps c'est leur choix genre on ai pas
voulu on les a remplacé on les a
remplacé par d'autres c'est vrai que au
début la la chaîne elle avait un peu
peur elle me dit peut-être personne ne
voudra le faire mais en même temps on a
eu adan Isabelle lupert Luini Nathalie
baay on les a tous hein et ça fait
partie du succès de la série d'ailleurs
vu de l'extérieur quand même ce monde du
cinéma et du théâtre paraît un peu
superfici ci un milieu où il serait
difficile de de de créer des liens
profonds est-ce que c'est un mythe
est-ce que parout on se trompe ça non
excusez-moi les gens sont absolument pas
superficiel il y a des vrais
amitiés ce qui est pas toujours dans la
politique parce que on est en plus dans
un lieu politique moi j'ai quand même
fréquenté des des politiques moi je
disais toujours alors c'est peut-être
trop tôt de parler de de notre ami
seégolen royale mais il y a Segolen
royale et je sais pas et Martine auri
sur une un précipice elle regarde la mer
il y en a une qui rate le le le le elle
est prêt à tomber ni ni ségolin ni
martinebri retiendra la personne qui
tombe chez les actrices jamais vous
verrez ça il y aura toujours un truc
solidaire du reste on voit quand quand
certaines actrices euh qui ont été un
peu rival sont malades je moi j'ai eu
beaucoup la preuve de de de les de elle
s'appelle parce que il y a un truc et
même quand vous allez dans une dans une
voilà je trouve qu'il y a quand même une
vraie solidarité votre histoire à vous
avec le cinéma elle commence tôt votre
amour pour les acteurs et les actrices
aussi j'ai deux anecdotes qui semblent
avoir été des déclencheur et vous me
direz si j'ai raison ou pas à l'âge de 5
6 ans vous assistez à un tournage dans
une rue de Paris parce que votre père a
été recruté comme figurant spontané ce
film c'est l'affaire d'une nuit d'Henry
Verneuil et puis il y a à la télévision
la télévision qui a été fondamentale
dans votre votre histoire vous regardiez
avec attention les génériques de film et
vous notiez les noms des acteurs qui
défilaient puis vous faisiez des fiches
c'est vrai tout ça tout ça c'est vrai je
je pourrais vous les amener mes fiches
toujours le seul truc c'est que c'est
vrai que moi j'étais un un j'étais une
créature on peut dire de l'ORTF et
c'était une télévision n il y avait que
deux chaînes et que moi je m'ennuyais un
peu à hougat T mes parents était
commerçant et donc le voilà donc l'hiver
ou le gâ l'hiver puisque je viens
d'avoir une maison maintenant j'aimais
pas tout était fermé c'était un espèce
de de de de de de nomansland toutes ces
villeslà fermées et et l'étaé on mettait
en colonie de vacances parce que mes
parents avaient trop de travail donc je
nai jamais été j'ai jamais profité de la
saison du cinéma du casino c'est pour ça
que j'avais fait un premier livre qui
s'appelait casino d'hiver parce que
l'hiver
c'est là que je voyais le casino fermé
et je voyais des bouts d'affiches qui
tombaient voilà donc c'est vrai que la
télévision a été ma mon la TL voilà et
moi j'adorais donc Télé 7 jours je
faisais des fiches et le problème
maintenant vous voz un générique et je
voyais tous les feutons de seul à Paris
à à comment au bous sardel je voyais
tout toutes les séries et je notais je
faisais des fiches sur les ACT vous avez
correspondu avec C
acteurs vous avez étéag plus t oui la
première actrice c'est Marline Jobert
qui m'a pas répondu elle dit qu'elle m'a
répondu c'est faux elle m'a jamais
répondu mais après j'ai toujours aimé
Marline Jobert ça a été mon mon actrice
préférée et quand j'avais vu comment
l'astragal où j'aurais jamais dû rentrer
dans le cinéma ce sa est à nu tout le
temps dans dans le film à l'époque je
vais avoir 10 ans et et Alexandre
bienheureux c'est un film qui m'a vraim
viment qui m'a plu aussi donc ça a été
elle fait partie de mon pantéon du rest
j'en parle dans mon livre mais pour vous
dire que donc donc maintenant le
problème c'est qu'on a plus le temps de
noter les génériques vont trop vite
c'est même irrespectueux je trouve à la
lueur de celui que vous êtes aujourd'hui
Dominique mesneard quel conseil
donneriez-vous au petit garçon que vous
étiez avant qu'il ne se lance dans la
vie qu'est-ce que vous lui diriez de lui
dire ben de travailler ouais de de lire
de travailler et de enfin de lire
maintenant ils lisent plus mais de lire
parce que quand on lit ça aide h et de
ce mot travail revient beaucoup hein
dans votre discours aussi ben oui parce
que moi j'ai travaillé et puis travail
et récompense c'est-à-dire moi
j'appartiens à une génération où on vous
donnait pas tout tout de suite je me
souviens que pour la télévision à
l'époque la télévision tout le monde ne
l'avait pas on allait chez le voisin on
allait au catéchisme il y avait une
télévision mais on pouvait voir que le
jour du Seigneur vous imaginez et voilà
donc donc la télévision mes parents nous
l' on eu assez vite par rapport aux
autres mais il l'ont pas eu tout de
suite ils ont dit il faut que vous ayez
des bons résultats ton frère et toi pour
avoir la télévision et c'est vrai que la
récompense c'est quelque chose de
magnifique pourquoi les acteurs adorent
avoir des récompenses parce que c'est
lié au travail le milieu du cinéma vous
en étiez très loin vous l'avez dit hein
vous avez grandi en Normandie vos
parents tenaient une crèmerie puis un
petit supermarché vous dites mes parents
tenaient une épicerie un lieu de passage
de rencontrre et de partage qui a marqué
ma vie à façonn mon en rapport aux
autres et me manque cruellement
aujourd'hui pourquoi vous avez
l'impression qu'on partage moins
aujourd'hui qu'on se rencontre moins bah
oui parce que ma mère elle c'était la
ménie Grégoire d'ougat c'est-à-dire que
vous savez l'hiver il y avait moins
d'habitants que l'été l'était la preuve
on nous mettait en colonie et mais mais
parents travaillaient tellement don il
avait pas le temps vraiment de mais
l'hiver ma mère elle parlait avec les
clientes qui arrivaient le soir donc
c'était vraiment c'était
vraiment les femmes délaissées donc
j'entendais tout c'était comme un
théâtre vous dir comme un théâtre ouais
et et et ma mère en même temps alors mon
père lui était beaucoup plus moins
affectif parce que vous savez il y avait
quand même des gens qui avaient des
problèmes économique donc on ce qu'on
appelle le crédit ma mère faisait des
crédits voilà des crédits pour pour
pouvoir il payit à la fin du mois et ma
j'ai les souvenirs de de de mes parents
qui s'entendaient très bien ils ont vécu
toute leur vie ensemble à cause des
clients ma mère me dit mais j'aurais
fait crédit elle a elle viendra pas
enfin des trucs de GO donc tout ça a
fait partie d'un théâtre comme vous
dites et il y a une rencontre aussi qui
je crois a été importante dans votre vie
dans votre jeunesse c'est Madame
schunfeld votre prof de français au
lycée de daauville racontez-nous
pourquoi elle a été si importante parce
que j'ai venis d'arriver au lycée de
Dauville elle était prof de français
elle et moi j'arrivais de faire du
théâtre je devais être en seconde et oui
3e et donc
on dit il y a un cours de théâtre dans
le cadre du lycée et donc voilà donc j'y
vais elle était pas ma pro de français
la première année d'accord et donc je
vais la voir elle me dit voilà elle
commence à nous faire lire des textes
moi j'en étais un peu resté au théâtre
ce soir et là je commence à lire comment
les grands auteur
anouille monterland girodou et donc elle
nous a monté d'un cramp moi j'ai
toujours ça fait rire tout le monde
c'est ma Brigite Macron à moi elle m'a
fait lire et elle nous a emmené au
théâtre
ouais est à Laé
franise y avait DESS entiers quiai àamp
pour voir des des spectacles importants
comme mkin cherro et tout ça donc c'est
une femme sans elle j'aurais peut-être
pas pu faire ça elle m'a aidé et ma mère
elle elle disait franchement cette femme
elle est merveilleuse ma mère n'a jamais
été jalouse que des fois j'allais passer
des weekends en tout bien tout honneur
chez cette prof qui était où il y avait
plein de gens qui dormaient chez elle et
on parlait on répétait donc et là elle
vient de disparaître parce que vous avez
été acteur évidemment le public le sait
et vous le reconnaît vous vous avez joué
dans des dizaines de films La Petite
Voleuse la cité de la peur douce
meilleur espoir féminin est-ce que vous
vous auriez pariller sur vous en tant
qu'agent je non au début je me suis dit
je peux pas être acteur parce que j'ai
un défaut de
prononciation c'était l'autocensure ou
on vous l'a dit ah non c'est moi de
l'autocensure et quand je suis arrivé
arriv à Paris j'étais là à la rue
Blanche j'ai fait la classe de mise en
scène et de régie justement parce que je
me disais jamais on prendra mais t
j'étais la lucidité vous fait avancer
hein le fait d'être lucide fait qu'on
gagne du temps et que ce qui est
merveilleux dans mon cas c'est que
j'imaginais jamais de recevoir tout ce
que j'ai reçu et de de rencontrer les
grands cinéastes de rencontrer Claude
Berry de rencontrer paulanssky de
rencontrer saué gragier de fer en fin de
compte moi j'aurais imaginé être
régisseur d'un théâtre être assistant
d'un metur en scène de théâtre et jamais
être au devant comme ça c'est parce que
c'est ma passion qui a fait que que j'ai
que par exemple Claude Berry m'a dit tu
restes dans la maison tu veux à reine
production tu vas travailler à l'année
pour nous pour tous les castings des
films j'avais 21 ans donc il y a un
moment donné quelle incroyable
opportunité oui opportunité mais j'ai
suis les saisir et j'étais prêt à les
recevoir ouis nêche que j'ai jamais moi
j'étais ambitieux mais j'étais pasiste
et l'ambition quelquefois vous
récompense plus que vous attendez h
parmi toutes vos nombreuses casquettes
il y a aussi celle de militant politique
vous l'avez déjà un tout petit peu dit
vous n'avez jamais caché vos engagements
vos préférences et j'ai une archive
évidemment à vous proposer la voici vous
l'avez déjà repéré en arrivant ici je
vous la mets entre les mains et je la
décris pour pour nos téléspectateurs
c'est une AFF elle é belle là quand même
ouais bien sûr personne n'a jamais dit
le contraire mais éta B c'étaitépo où je
où j'étais un peu son coach mais coach
en fait quand on a dit tout et n'importe
quoi j'étais militant j'ai rencontré je
l'ai aidé dans mes dans on a fait
charletti quand même j'ai mais j'étais
dans un état second hein c'estàdire que
toutes mes am un meeting à à charlti un
meeting qui a été très marquant dans
cette camp moi j'ai vraiment participé
sauf que toutes mes amies actrices elle
supportait pas qu'est-ce qu'elle ne
supportait pas mais tu te vois pas que
tu parce qu'elle étaaient peut-être un
peu jalouse parce que je passais que du
temps avec ceses j'étais plus agent
j'étais devenu producteur donc elle a
été dans la jonction entre être agent et
être producteur et en fin de compte
c'est quelqu'un que que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié presque j'ai aimé d'amour mais
ça c'est mal fini je crois oui c'est
c'est elle qui qui a pas s'est pas rendu
compte B oui ça c'est très mal fini
parce que j'ai été faire le festival
d'angoulem et comme c'est goen on peut
pas lui résister c'est que j'ai dit non
à quelque chose elle l'a mal pris elle
l'a mal pris elle m'a écarté et comme je
voulais pas faire de politique elle
s'est un peu vengé sur le festival
d'angoulem et donc j'ai plus de
subvention de la Région et donc j'ai
trouvé ça injuste sauf que vous savez
dans la vie on récolle ce qu'on s'aime
et Bertrand de la Noé était le maire de
Paris et lui pouvait donner une
subvention pour une ville pour un un
événement culturel ou et donc
cé angoulem et la francoponie et nous a
aidé et on a pu résister vous lui en
voulez toujours à Souen Royal non j'en
veux pas je me dis c'est elle qui est
qui qui qui c'est s problème à elle hein
le le 2007 vous avez donc soutenu cgolen
Royal 2016 vous avez coigné une tribune
pour défendre François Hollande qui
était victime d'une campagne de
dénigrement 2021 vous saluez le
programme culturel de Valérie PCR au
régionale 2022 vous appelez à la
réélection d'Emmanuel Macron finalement
vous êtes très impliqué dans le monde
politique et dans plusieurs camps
politiques j'allais dire plusieurs non
parce que moi je je j'aime les personnes
ah Valérie PC excusez-moi dans la région
elle fait un bon boulot en tout cas pour
la culture pour le cinéma elle a fait
énormément donc vous ne regardez pas le
parti vous regardez si mais en plus
quand on voit valer pcrè c'est pas la
droite dure moi je suis en fin de compte
j'étais centre gauche peut-être que je
suis devenu centre- droit moi j'ai
complètement appelé à à à voter Macron
je connais Macron je vois toutes les
erreurs qu'il a faites HM des bons
acteurs aussi hein les hommes et les
femmes politiques non lui euh de temps
en temps il en fait trop hein Emmanuel
Macron bah oui il est trop long déjà
mais c'est quelqu'un que je connais
j'aime beaucoup sa femme j'ai connais
j'ai rencontre beaucoup avec avec l
Renaud qui est quand même une amie très
très proche donc voilà mais je de temps
en temps il en fait un peu trop mais il
s'est amélioré quand même pu des
discours trop longs mais il a une espèce
de Foug il a une espèce de voilà et en
même temps dans le dans la la situation
actuelle moi par je me dis heureusement
qu'il est là parce qu'on aurait qui
voilà ou parce qu'il y en a que vous
n'épargnez pas c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon
très bon acteur dites-vous mais il
serait le pire président que l'on
pourrait avoir ah benah le pire vous
avez vu là il y a quelques jours par
rapport à Israël vous avez vu ces
déclarations mais c'est lamentable tu un
malade moi je pense que c'est un malade
est-ce que vous ne voyez pas Jean-Luc
mélencha un grand acteur finalement un
grand acteur au début non mais comme
comme les jeunes on sont pas culture il
va quelqu'un de plus brillant que toute
la classe politique donc il disent il
parl bien maintenant on préfère il parle
bien il était beau autrefois moi je me
souviens dans ma famille mais tente à
dire c'est quand même le plus beau
Chirac hein dis mais qu'est-ce qu'il dit
et bien maintenant heureuse comme
maintenant on préfère quelqu'un qui
parle bien mais moi je pense surtout que
il est dangereux et moi je n'ai pas peur
de dire ce que je pense ce typ est
dangereux et donc moi voilà et la gauche
c'est pas ça c'était pas la gauche que
je voulais voilà et donc alors peut-être
que la la social déémocratie elle
n'existe plus mais en tout cas ce type
est
dangereux j'ai des photos à vous
proposer ça fait partie des rituels de
cette émission nos invités sont soumis à
l'exercice de la photo première photo
que j'ai à vous présenter Dominique Bard
il s'agit de Francis Huster qui vous a
sauvé la vie tout le public n'est pas
forcément au courant mais vous avez fait
un malaise cardiaque devant lui un arrêt
cardiaque et il a eu le très bon réflexe
d'arrêter un camion de pompier qui
passait c'est un peu ça enfin il a
surtout un camion pompier passé par là
non il a surtout le eu le mieux que
pompier parce que le pompier c'était le
le hasard mais surtout qu'il a vu que
dans le le van j'étais en train de
tomber il a vu il a dit arrêons arrêtons
il il est en train de passer le d'ê dans
le trou noir c'est lui qui a eu la la
réaction ce qu'on m'a dit et puis moi
j'avais un ami Hubert qui était là qui
m'a dit qu'ensuite et il y a un jeune
qui est venu un petit black qu'on a
jamais retrouvé et ensuite il passait
des pompiers en face et on est allé les
chercher et ils ont vu qu'il y avait un
attroupement ils sont venus et c'est lui
mais c'est Francis qui a senti s'il
avait voyez on dit qu'un acteur il est
sur lui-même en tout cas il là il pas
sur lui-même qu'est-ce que ça a changé
dans votre vie de de d'être passé si
près de la mort est-ce que il y a
quelque chose qui a changé que vous avez
changé depuis et bien j'y pense plus j'y
pense plus qu'avant et puis c'est aussi
ce livre je me suis dit c'est le moment
de faire ce livre de raconter un peu
l'histoire de ma vie mais c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas triste he au
contraire une deuxième photo la voici
vous n'z pas reconnaître tout de suite
mais je vais vous la décrire c'est la
photo du cinéma le César à Marseille
cinéma historique de la place Castellane
ouvert par Marcel Pagnol en 38
exactement qui a été obligé de fermer
ses portes impossible de payer les
loyers il a souffert de la crise
sanitaire et puis les salles obscures
souffrent se vident un peu vous pensez a
plus de cinéma un jour temp jamais les
gens envieent de se rencontrer mais il y
a plein de cinéma qui ouvrent là à mon
avis c'est une mauvaise gestion mais la
la ville qu'elle fait parce qu' attendez
moi je je voyage beaucoup dans la France
profonde dans toutes les villes il y a
un cinéma bourguf où chaque année je
vais il y a un cinéma de de salles là
quand j'ai était il y a quelques jours à
au man il y a des les salles sont
immenses avec des des des écans
formidables là c'est peut-être aussi le
la gestion vous voyez la clé ce cinéma
qui a été fermé va réouvrir donc à un
moment donné et c'est en France grâce au
CNC qu'on peut avoir des subventions
donc je sais pas peut-être que National
du Cinéma voilà cent national du cinéma
qui est que tout le monde nous envie où
chaque
où on on permet grâce sur chaque ticket
vendu on prend un petit impôt qu'on
reverse au cinéma français pour donc
voilà donc franchement je ne sais pas la
raison mais je pense que ça pas je suis
sûr que c'est pas simptomatique c'est
pas symptomatique VO on est entouré de
quatre statutes Dominique besneard dans
ce lieu magique du DOM Tournon quatre
statutes qui représente chacune une
vertu il y a la sagesse la prudence la
justice et les éloquence est-ce qu'il y
a une de ces vertus qui vous caractéris
dans laquelle vous vous reconnaissez le
plus alors l'autre c'est quoi sagesse pr
la prudence non la preuve la sagesse pas
trop non plus non la justice c'est la
justice moi j'aurais adoré être avocat
voyez si j'étais pas enfin aussi un
problème avec le cheveux sur la langue
quand même si j'avais été avoc oui mais
ça aurait été compliqué n'empêche que
j'adore la justice j'aime bien aller à
la la comparitiontion immédiate hm hm
vous savez et là où il y a personne je
me mets dans un coin et je vois l'état
l'état de de certaines personnes de la
France pauvre des laissés pour compte et
on se dit mais comment on peut les
sortir de là j'ai beaucoup d'estime pour
le pour les les gens qui travaillent
dans la justice la justice donc merci
merci infiniment Dominique bner d'avoir
été notreité ici au Tournon merci
d'avoir été dans ce rendez-vous un monde
un regard merci à vous et merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi émission évidemment
que vous pouvez retrouver en podcast
vous le savez désormais merci beaucoup à
très bientôt sur public
[Musique]
sa